there should be a couple seats around
grabble if you can welcome to the
International Spy Museum my name is
Vince Houghton I'm the historian and
curator here at spy I like to welcome
you to another one of our author
debriefing programs on a rare Friday
night so we're really appreciative of
you coming out tonight I think has a lot
to do with who we have here with us we
are pleased to have Annie Jacobson here
at the Spy Museum
she's an investigative journalist and
best-selling author who writes books
about war weapons u.s. national security
and government secrecy not to mention
intelligence her 2011 nonfiction
bestseller area 51 and uncensored
history of America's top secret military
base has been published in five
languages as has her 2014 nonfiction
bestseller Operation Paperclip The
Secret Intelligence program that brought
Nazi scientists to America the Boston
Globe and Apple iTunes chose Operation
Paperclip
as one of the best books of 2014 her
newest book the Pentagon's brain
uncentered history uncensored history of
DARPA America's top-secret military
research agency was published on Tuesday
and after reading and I'm fairly sure it
won't take long before it joins her
other two books is the bestseller Thank
You Annie for coming to the
International Spy Museum thank you so I
wanted to ask you just as we get going
do you have on your bookshelf at home
copies of your books in all five
languages yeah copies of your books in
all five languages on your bookshelf at
home I actually do they're really really
cool for the Chinese one in particular
that's not on my car I had to ask that
so one thing that we always want to do
when we have authors here especially
considering that our authors tend to
write about a field that's not
necessarily the most conducive to
getting information and documents so the
secret world of intelligence or national
security and it's really a two-part
question it's it's how did you come
across the idea of writing a book about
DARPA and how in the world do you find
the sources necessary to write a full
sized non-fiction book about a very
top-secret agency that does things that
they don't necessarily want historians
to know
well for starters I want to thank some
of those sources Paul thank you for
coming Neal and some folks in the back
thank you I the way that I got the idea
for writing the Pentagon's brain
actually came as most of my books do on
the tail end of the last book and when I
was learning about what von Braun was
doing in 58 I was surprised to learn
that he was the going to be the first
director of this new agency at the
Pentagon called ARPA and and he wanted
to be the director however he had one
stipulation which was he wanted to bring
12 of his former Nazi colleagues with
him and that did not fly at the Pentagon
so they looked elsewhere for a director
and that director was herb York but I
thought what a spicy way to start out an
agency with controversy with secrecy
with backstory and so I immediately
looked into it and when I learned how
little has actually been written about
DARPA I really thought this because it's
gonna be a great book which is
surprising to me because it has a
science geek I mean DARPA is something
I've known about for quite some time and
will talk for those of you that don't
know a lot about DARPA and maybe we
should say it's the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency just to get
that out of the way and for clarity's
sake it was called ARPA at one point now
it's DARPA we'll just call it DARPA just
to keep it consistent as we'll talk
about tonight there are some major
innovations that we use in our everyday
lives that as a result of DARPA research
so when your book came out or when the
idea of it I'm like the hash to event of
the book about Nara and of course there
hasn't been a major work of this level
um in the last said was a great segue so
I want to talk about the origins of
DARPA and why it really comes about and
a little bit about what it is as an
organization's I think DUP is different
than a lot of the other military
research organizations in that it's not
really a military research organization
in a sense in that it doesn't really do
scientific research if you talked a
little bit about how DARPA is formulated
well DARPA has
approximately a hundred and twenty
program managers and has almost its
entire existence working with a three
billion dollar budget and yet these
individuals themselves are scientists
engineers at the top of their game so
they go out into the field be it
academic laboratories or other military
laboratories and they put together teams
that bring forth this incredible science
and technology and in essence create
entire industries and what we'll talk
about couple of those industries because
they're incredibly important you had
alluded to the impetus behind why DARPA
was formed and he said 1958 and and I
think as a historian dates matter
certainly but there's a real significant
reason that DARPA was formed in 1958 it
was it follows in the footsteps of some
pretty monumental events in world
history can you talk a little bit about
what caused the United States government
to think they need an agency like this
well I hope in the book with seen the
explosion of the Castle Bravo
thermonuclear bomb in the Marshall
Islands this massive 15 Megaton
explosion four years before DARPA has
formed but I do that because I think
it's important to know the reason why
DARPA was formed and that was initially
to defend against this weapon in essence
which there is no defense against and
that brings us to the heart of the idea
of the military-industrial complex and
this idea that we must always be supreme
we must have these incredible weapons to
stay ahead of the enemy and yet at the
same time there's a knowledge built-in
that the enemy will eventually have that
same technology and so we must be on to
the next and that that is that give and
take that Eisenhower talks about but
specifically when Sputnik was launched
and that idea that whatever lofted
Sputnik that Soviet long-range missile
could carry a nuclear warhead in its
nose cone to the United States that gave
birth to DARPA and the idea was we must
never again be taken by technological
surprise and it is amazing that in all
the years since DARPA has really always
kept America in the pole position kept
us the strongest there has never
been and overtaking of American science
and technology in terms of weaponry and
we're both too young to remember this
time period but there may be some of the
audience who are of more wise age now
remember that the the fear of nuclear
war back during the 1950s and in the
fear that even trickled down into the
scientific world this is a period where
robert Oppenheimer who helped build the
american atomic bomb because he speaks
out against the hydrogen bomb is
stripped of his security clearance is
simply stigmatized and the idea that the
Soviets could overtake us just about any
day the bomber and missile gaps and
everything else led in many ways to the
idea that you have to stay ahead
technologically well here's an
interesting detail one of the first
things that herb York did as director of
ARPA was determined and I don't think
this had been reported before I found it
in her Bjork's files actually was that
he had ARPA scientists calculate the
exact number of seconds it took for a
Soviet ICBM to get from the Soviet Union
to Washington DC it's an astonishingly
short time it is 1,600 seconds that is
it that has not changed and so in
essence that threat that was there then
is still there now so enter a person
most people haven't heard of Neil
McElroy who was a secretary of defense a
very important secretary defense but
before that and I think that you do a
great job and kind of laying out his
personality a little bit a lot of
secretary defenses like McNamara come
from the world of academia and there are
statisticians or you get current
secretary defenses that are policy wonks
he wasn't in the defense world before he
became secretary fence you even when
Elena mount as a PR guru somebody that
really understood how to do brand
management you talked a little bit about
that reward of all things he invented
the concept of the soap opera and he was
a leading guy in the advertising
department at P&G and he was in charge
of soaps and he was trying they had four
soaps that were competing with one
another and he thought how are we gonna
sell more soap well let's play during
these soap operas and then he became the
Secretary of Defense and
very powerful one at that well and that
really comes in handy because one of the
first things he has to do with is this
idea of DARPA is not something that very
palatable to the military agencies to
the Atomic Energy Commission to the
other organizations that is competing
with and he has to convince all of them
that this is an idea that's worth doing
yes oh there was serious pushback from
the military agencies in some of these
old ARPA documents I found the you know
McIlroy would meet with the individual
heads trying to convince them that ARPA
was a great idea the army said no no it
should be our territory military science
and research specifically space they
said the moon is just higher ground and
then the Admirals
in the Navy we're saying no no no space
should be our territory because we're
the oceans and space starts and so
everybody had a reason why they wanted
to control space which was really why
how ARPA came to be what fascinates me
about this time period about science in
general is that even sometimes the
scientists don't know what they've
created they don't necessarily
understand the magnitude you talked
about castle Bravo that was a much
larger explosion than what was expected
I focus on the Manhattan Project and
they had no idea whatsoever if that bomb
was gonna work during the Trinity test
they were taking bets would it set the
atmosphere on fire would it not work at
all and the great story that you talk
about here of the beam use the the
ballistic missile early warning system
and how that almost started World War 3
okay not without giving away half your
book yes this is an anecdote I think it
is a wonderful can you please going to
lay that out for us yes so ARPA set up a
facility at the top of the world near
the Thule Air Force Base it was about 15
miles north of it and the idea was that
that it was called j' site and it was
going to be the place where we could
watch for it was a it was a ballistic
missile radar early warning site and
what I in turf ello as I do I always try
to tell my stories through individual
people who were there and there was a
fellow named Jean McManus who was an
electronics technician
he the way he described it to me was our
job was 90% boredom and 10% sheer terror
and one of the first things that
happened the J site had only been open a
few days it was October of 1960 and the
J site was connected directly to no rat
and there was this idea of you know
level 1 level 2 level 3 level 5 was
endgame but it always started if you
were to get a notice that something was
detected it was always be level 1 and it
would usually you know go away but the
notice came in level 3 and by the time
the operator in Cheyenne Mountain was on
the phone with you know the Joint Chiefs
of Staff it had escalated to level 5
which meant with 99.9% certainty we were
under attack by a thousand ICBMs and you
know someone picked up the phone and
what was determining the reason why I
think this story is important as it
talks a lot about humans versus
computers because these were very early
computers and one of the humans in the
Mex said wait a minute where is
Khrushchev and someone said why he's in
New York City you know banging his shoe
at the UN and there was this moment when
everyone said there must be a mistake
and in fact there was a mistake and what
had happened someone up at J site said
let's go out and foo Thurmond look
outside and of course there was this
giant moon coming up over Norway and so
this radar system had actually worked
better than expected it was supposed to
detect missiles up to 3,000 feet and it
actually read the reflection of the moon
a quarter of a million miles away and
bounced back and forth so many times
those were the thousand ICBMs that were
not coming so disaster was averted by a
human early technology is always a
little tricky here at the Spy Museum we
certainly focus on the technological
aspects of intelligence and one of these
is imagery intelligence and DARPA was
heavily influential in some of the first
imagery intelligence satellites that
were put in a space is one of the
fundamental jobs of DARPA was this early
satellite program
Korona which some people may know about
is the first real American satellite was
inherited by DARPA from the Air Force
they really saw that fraud that program
to fruition and the idea of the SIGINT
satellites and imagery satellites and
you see these start to leak into the
civilian world a little bit and I'm not
gonna screw up the acronym of Kiros
television infrared observation
satellite program this is the first true
weather satellite well that was I mean
Eisenhower in particular loved that
program he was so amazed and by then
NASA had actually inherited that
satellite program that DARPA started but
these were these amazing images it was
in space for I think 79 days only they
were very short-lived these early
satellites and it took something like
23,000 photographs above the earth of
the earth and just imagine I mean in
this world where were we always see so
much from with such big perspective
imagine back that idea that these were
the first images of weather seen from
space and they were beautiful and
Eisenhower spoke of that and I write
about it you know he saw you know what
it looked like over Egypt he saw what it
looked like over the st. Lawrence River
he could see the whole world in these
photographs and he spoke to the nation
about it you know with kind of a great
pride and then they became you know in
big national geographic spread but it
was a really interesting time and not
that long ago in the big picture of
things when we could first see things
from space you'd mentioned in your very
beginning of your conversation that the
tarp essentially uses smartest
scientists in the country you round up
the top people and this started from the
very beginning and I want to talk about
one of these assembled scientists that
had a very particular name the Jason's
because to me this is something that
people just don't know about and that
the amount of influence the Jason's had
over American foreign policy still have
today over American foreign policy is is
pretty extraordinary and the first
Jason's were assembled right after DARPA
was assembled in
nine led by a man named Charles Townes
who you may or may not know Charles
Towne team that did something very
important to us but can you talk a
little bit about the Jason's and and
what they do and kind of how their job
has continued until today the Jason's
began in 1960 as a group of well they
were referred to by their government
handlers as the Superman of hard science
they were astrophysicists they were
nuclear physicists they handled tackled
all the hard problems and immediately
when DARPA was founded the idea was we
need exactly as you said we need the
best guys with the biggest minds and for
a while Jason's only customer was ARPA
DARPA I had the great fortune of
interviewing a fellow named Marvin Murph
Goldberger who was a presidential
science advisor was also the founder of
co-founder of the Jason's I write about
him in the book he just passed but it
was interesting hearing his perspective
we interviewed in 2000 and like his long
lens of history working on these
projects going back to the 60s the
Jason's are so misunderstood as being
these kind of some people consider them
to be right up there with the Illuminati
in terms of you know these guys cooking
up these ideas but I actually found from
reading their unclassified reports and
interviewing some of them that there
they were very cautious in their work
and they they were also full-time
academics and part-time defense science
scientists they would only gathers in
the summers and discuss these big
problems that the Secretary of Defense
would put to them and say sort this out
right you know it wasn't the easy
problems it was the very very difficult
ones that nobody else could figure out
that they were handed like hey we have
no idea what to do with this you fix it
and amazingly their track record is
pretty spectacular the I'll say the the
unclassified documents that are that you
can read that I read are one thing but
the classified documents some of the
names of the documents have been deke
if I'd only the names but when you read
them you realize I couldn't understand
that even if it was Declassified I mean
just it is such literal literally hard
science
DARPA really comes of age during the
Vietnam whoa in a lot of this place are
their their trial by fire in many
respects you know in a lot of the things
that are you know looked at in Vietnam
as being potentially problematic about
the war were things that DARPA either
tried to get rid of or were the cause of
and some of the respects they were the
first ones really to appreciate the idea
of trying to defeat a insurgency with
technology maybe not the first one to
think of it that was really their
primary focus during Vietnam was high
tech in counterinsurgency strategy can
you talk a little bit about this with
the extent of things like psychological
operations using soft science like
anthropology and sociology
I mean Vietnam was a very interesting
time for for the for ARPA and many
different programs came out of it I mean
they were working on as you say soft
science anthropology programs they were
also working on conventional weapons the
ar-15 was a DARPA a DARPA weapon that's
now the m16 they were you know early
gliders which kind of led to stealth
technology but the one that I found the
most impactful was the idea of that
sensor technology the Ho Chi Minh Trail
was sort of the dreaded problem of the
Pentagon and all of the fighters the
insurgents would come from the north to
the south by way of this trail and the
Secretary of Defense tasked the Jason
scientists with figuring out a way to
stop this I mean they really saw it
almost like it was a human and it needed
to you know have its artery severed and
the Jason scientists and a lot of their
documents spoke about it that way I mean
it was it was really like that was the
locus and so they tried they thought
about nuclear weapons that was not an
option it was discussed and then this
idea of an electronic fence which the
reason that I write
about this and found it so interesting
to really explore was because all this
sensor technology you know seismic
sensors which had by the way come from
the Vela program that you referred to
audio sensors magnetic sensors these
were incredibly early ideas during the
Vietnam War and now they make up so much
of our existence I mean I'm sure driving
here
somebody's windshield wipers just
started to work you know as a drop of
rain well that's essentially technology
that goes back I the way I see it to
that Vietnam War to the sensors that the
jasons were working on is massive
technology that still today is used
throughout the Intelligence Agency but
also in civilian practice I'm sure one
of us drove over one of the sensors on
the ground will determine how fast we're
going or anything else like that Vietnam
was also a time where DARPA began to
invest in some more questionable
technologies Agent Orange certainly is
one of these technologies also things
that I find very interesting as weather
modification technologies so you know
more devious things but also more kind
of outside the box thinking about
potentially winning the war through
causing monsoons or changing the ability
of the Vietnamese to grow food and to
move weapons from one A to point B I
mean they were were and continue to be
always at the cutting edge of science
and DARPA is an agency that's looking
you know at the problem twenty years 25
years they like it's it's spoken off as
pre requirement research and that takes
us again back to that idea of the
military-industrial complex it was one
of the DARPA directors Steven Lukasik
who spoke to Congress after the Vietnam
War when DARPA got in some trouble you
know by Congress saying you guys were
making weapons we don't need and Luque
Sixpoint he called it the chicken the
egg problem he said listen if if a need
for a weapon system comes along and we
haven't already developed it there's a
real problem and that's the chicken and
the egg problem I want to talk a little
bit about civilian use of some of the
technologies developed by DARPA because
this is where the audience that they
hadn't heard of this agency before will
go oh that's where that's problem so
let's start with who is
see our Licklider Licklider is often
referred to as the Johnny Appleseed of
the internet he really is the man who is
responsible for that for what we have
today as the internet that technology
used by almost half the people on the
planet and that began at as an art
project the internet was originally
called the ARPANET and Licklider came to
the Pentagon to ARPA when in 1962 when
Congress decided there was a really big
technology problem and if you can
imagine the idea of a red phone that was
the technology that President Kennedy
and Khrushchev had to use either one of
them to make that dreaded go no-go
nuclear decision and mindful that there
are sixteen hundred seconds till
doomsday
imagine wasting 30 seconds trying to
dial a rotary phone and so the Pentagon
said we need command and control and
they hire and Licklider came to ARPA
specifically to work on this problem
this very hard problem and he was a
really eccentric thinker and one of his
early memos talked about this idea of an
intergalactic network where he was going
to have all these computers that somehow
spoke to each other and were tied
together and everyone sort of said yeah
work on the command and control problem
but later of course that materializes in
a very big way
and that becomes the ARPANET which is
the Internet when people have gone back
computer scientist have gone back and
looked at some of lick lighters writings
and he essentially predicts cloud
computing in his earliest writings I
mean this is again in the 1960s it's
somewhat similar to Alan Turing yes
talking about artificial intelligence
that's nowhere near created even today
back during that time you know it's it's
hard not to talk about Licklider not
only for the internet but also has a
kind of a computer modeling pioneer
about how a lot of the data systems
today are used to create models for
either everything from wargames to
weather planners and everything else you
talked a little bit about that as well
yes and many people do not know that
about Licklider and he did have you know
I often wonder and I write this in the
book I wonder what his intentions were
because he was very liberal in his
thinking and very transparent I mean
obviously had this idea of sharing
everything but at the same time he was
involved in one of the more
controversial programs of the Vietnam
War which had to do with behavior
modeling with computers so the new
computer systems over in Thailand at the
information centers were gathering
information based on these Licklider
ideas of behavior modeling so we would
for example you know keep track of what
certain villagers were doing in these
various strategic Hamlet programs feed
that into information into these giant
computers with the idea that down the
road we could track these individuals
find them follow them see how they wound
up and this gets into very awkward
territory I think for the Pentagon today
having to do with surveillance programs
because they do link to one another and
see Lenny yes yes yes who is Jack Thorpe
as I think Thorpe kind of builds upon a
lot of what Leiter was doing before well
and not to embarrassment we have Neil
Cosby here today who is working with
Jack Thorpe after the internet the you
know this idea came around that
computers were incredibly helpful and
that they could be used as a training
tool and so Jack Thorpe had this idea of
creating you know a system instead of
using an old sand table to have generals
make ideas it could be computerized and
this was profound thinking and also
Thorpe was not cleared on the ARPANET at
that point so it's really prescient of
him and and it eventually became an ARPA
program
Wired magazine referred to Jack Thorpe
as the father of cyberspace in essence
because that civilian technology that
everyone knows today and the everyone's
children in the audience probably works
on the MMO GS and plays these games
these giant systems find their origin in
the program that Jack Thorpe and Neil
Cosby ended up running at Ida for the
generals at the Pentagon who wanted to
play those games and throw a little
stealth in to the equation and that
filtered all the way down to the ground
level I mean I I was in the Army as a
tanker and I was on simnet
with other thousands of other people
around the country working together so
and that jumped at it early in the book
as well there are other civilian
technologies like GPS is a DARPA
brainchild as our non-lethal
technologies used for like SWAT teams
things like that can get kind of close
out this conversation about the civilian
use with a couple of those technologies
GPS is an amazing one and it also you
know one thing that DARPA does so well
and this has to do with the this from
the scientists and engineers that I
spoke with so many of them almost all of
them are incredibly gung-ho DARPA and
they talk about how DARPA finds the
solutions to things and DARPA allows
scientists to push science in a way that
maybe their industry bosses wouldn't
allow them to because it might not seem
like such a good idea but DARPA thinking
of the future
DARPA likes to say DARPA makes the
future happen but another thing that
they do is they and this is sort of in
the spirit of how Eisenhower created or
saw this initial idea was that it would
cut out inter-service rivalry GPS being
a great example of that originally an
art program they lofted these satellites
and then in the 70s the Navy started
having its own GPS program and so did
the Air Force and then the orders came
from the Pentagon that said wait a
minute this is not working the way it
should as one system for all the
agencies and so DARPA was put back on
the program and then ultimately they
created a system called Navstar
which is the GPS that we have today
there was a fascinating detail that I
did not know that GPS was working away
we all just didn't know about it and
didn't use it yes and it had a little
feature because it was a targeting idea
that was what the military application
was but it had a feature built-in called
selective availability so if someone in
Europe let's say or Asia could very
easily hack into the system the Pentagon
didn't want them to know for targeting
reasons how close it was
so they created about a hundred or 150
foot offset and then in the early 90s
moving toward the late 90s Europe
started developing GPS and saying well
we're going to create an industry with
this and then President Clinton made the
system public got rid of the SA feature
and because America could greatly
benefit from having that technology just
ask Google and so now we all have GPS
although it has been around for quite
some time that was a fascinating detail
the book that I didn't know I'm not
either I I was in the military before
Clinton took away that feature and we
always wondered why we couldn't use
civilian GPS because they were much
smaller I mean even at that time so be
in Jesus and the pluggers which is that
what we called the big military GPS like
no you got to use that one and see all
I'm like now I know why I couldn't use
let's move a little bit into the modern
period as we already a.m. and I think
things that we use or that are used I
said we've is our next military see
everywhere on a modern battlefield owe
their existence in many ways to DARPA
things like night vision and thermal x'
things like stealth technology and
laser-guided munitions things like
drones you talk a little bit of drones
are something that we here at the spy
news and pay a lot of attention to and
talk a little bit more about how a lot
of the current military technology is
because of this agency DARPA is very
much about brilliance and hubris it's
about these incredible in my estimation
it's about these incredible programs
it's about pushing science and so one
must really ask questions about where we
are now and looking at the technology
that we have now looking at that drone
technology that came out of Vietnam so
this is a decade's old technology and
mindful of that idea that we're always
ahead so when drones hit the battlefield
in Afghanistan we were allegedly the
only nation who had armed drones and now
a hundred and eighty-six nations have
armed drones so in essence the predator
is obsolete in some regard so the
question is what's next and that idea
when you really look at DARPA you know
moving information technology
biotechnology which we did not have a
time to discuss I write about it at
length in the book
nanotechnology the art of making things
small what I learned from unclassified
Pentagon documents is that the agency is
really moving or rather the Pentagon is
moving toward autonomous warfare that is
the plan
for 25 years out and that is the idea of
self-governance and drones and the way
that the Pentagon sees it is a is a four
part step you know we start with you
know remote control and we move toward
governance and so this gets into some
heady territory because there are
questions about ethics and there are
questions about robots that can do
things without an operator in the loop
but these are certainly all places where
where DARPA technology is taking us well
in an if DARPA scientists have their way
in 25 years a human on the battlefield
will not be fully human artificial human
enhancement they need all of the
projects DARP is working on let's not
use the word cyborgs but let's you know
the idea of you know brainwave
interfaces and cybernetics these are
things that you know 10 years ago or the
realm of science fiction and now are
becoming truer and truer every day well
I would use the word cyborg but DARPA
uses the word bio hybrid and that's an
idea where you couple animal with
machine and DARPA has already been able
to do that in these amazing ways with a
rat you know electrodes and the in the
brain being able to remotely control a
rat now a moth and so from these
Pentagon documents what is clear is that
it's moving humans in the military
environment toward being comfortable
with this idea of merging man and
machine that makes a lot of people
uncomfortable it makes a lot of other
people excited it just depends where you
fall along the lines of transhumanism
this idea that essentially we can now
create our own evolution we can engineer
our own evolution no it may sound like
science fiction I thought that wasn't
one of the interesting things you talk
about in the book is the Sigma group
which are actual science fiction writers
that have been brought in to work with
DARPA to think
about the future in some cases we talk a
little bit about that yes there I mean
depending on love science fiction
writers they're thinking right along the
lines of you know the ideas of the
future I mean Charles Townes you
mentioned him earlier he invented the
laser and he won the Nobel Prize for it
in 1964 and when I was not getting many
answers about laser weapons from present
people at the Pentagon they're very
highly classified for obvious reasons I
had a discussion with Townes who was
still giving interviews aged 98 in his
office at Berkeley it was really an
incredible interview but he told me that
the way he got the idea for inventing
the laser now considered one of the most
important technologies of the present
day for military and civilian use
but the way Townes got the idea was way
back in 1926 when he was a little boy in
bed reading a science-fiction book
called the Guerin
Death Ray and that inspired him to
create the laser so no wonder the
Pentagon is interested in science
fiction absolutely you've talked several
times about Eisenhower and the
military-industrial complex and I think
anyone who listens to anything you've
talked about tonight who read your book
who knows a little bit about DARPA has
to be concerned at some level about the
influence of the billions and billions
of dollars being spent by the defense
industry and you even say in your book
and you talk about the idea that the
people who are pulling many of the first
strings the defense Science Board
they're not made up of scientists or
engineers in many cases are made up of
well they are but they're scientists and
engineers from Boeing and Lockheed
Martin and defense industries is that
something we should be concerned about
is that something that has changed in
any way is that how DARPA was in the
beginning or is it much ado about
nothing or is this something that is
going to mean a continued militarization
I sound like a tree-hugging yeah I am a
little bit but I sound more than
trying to medina quirk is this is this
potentially problematic as we move
forward i mean it's an important
question and i certainly raise it at the
end of the book i mean i always keep in
mind that my job as as a journalist is
to report the facts to the public it's
hard when you get to the end to not have
some conclusions i think people like
that as they stay with you through this
narrative and so one of the conclusions
that i ask people to contemplate is
exactly the what you're talking about
and that is the idea of the
military-industrial complex having a
little bit too much power I mean
Eisenhower warned against it in his 1961
speech but he also said that the two
ideas could live together as long as you
have an alert and knowledgeable
citizenry you can have this powerful
military-industrial complex and I
believe they interchange the problem
that I came across was actually had to
do with the Jason scientists when I went
to interview a very sort of famous
program manager from DARPA who was
responsible for a lot of this
transhumanism early programs in 1990
2000 and I and we were discussing the
the brain implant programs that are
moving man
you know merging man with machine in
ways that make some people uncomfortable
and I said to him about you know I had
read a jayson report that the Jason
scientists had counseled the Pentagon
that this was a bad idea that we should
not be putting brain chips in people's
brains in essence because it could lead
toward brain control that's the Jason
scientists the Superman of science
that's their assessment not mine
you know the steerable moth the
steerable rat could essentially become
the steerable human and I was told that
the Jason scientists aren't really
relevant anymore that what is the group
that has become more important is the
defense Science Board who is an in-house
Pentagon think-tank and you know they
advise the president I mean there are
very knowledgeable supermen of science
in their own right question mark because
what is also true is that unlike the
Jason scientists who were full-time
academics and part time defense
scientists
the defense Science Board members as
their list explains our defense
contractors and they sit on the boards
of a lot of these defense contractors
which raises the question that
Eisenhower raised not me which is let's
make sure that the citizenry maintains a
knowledge that they're aware of what the
military-industrial complex is planning
to do is in that same speech where he
warns about the military-industrial
complex he warns about the scientific
technological elite having unwarranted
influence over the country as well well
we're gonna open it up to questions from
you wait one sec we please raise your
hand we are gonna have microphones
coming around so they can be picked up
by by the cameras laura is grabbing them
right now so if you keep your hands up
they will come to you all right yep
right over there and then we see you
here as well yes sir so do you have any
examples of where the influence goes the
other way where the DARPA scientists are
seeing something that's going on in the
civilian world and kind of build upon it
and create technology yes it's a great
question I mean the place where I
observed that have to do with a
situation in the war on terror in Iraq
where DARPA created a program called
combat zones that see and the idea was
to use that advanced second sensor
technology what was once the Vietnam
electronic fence is now the combat zone
that can see so it's multi angle drones
overhead sensors on the ground cameras
to really get an idea of this urban
warfare environment which is so
difficult to defend against and from
what I understand is the Pentagon DARPA
followed the Google Maps model and sent
contractors into the field to map the
territory the very similar to how Google
Maps had done and of course now we know
there are those partnerships as well up
here Amanda
yes thank you so much for your first two
I'm looking forward to this one I was on
a consultant team with a man who
consulted for DARPA also what I believe
was a paperclip scientist and my
question is how were there many
paperclip scientists involved with DARPA
and how were they vetted that's a great
question in all of my research I did not
come across any of the paperclip
scientists which by no means means they
weren't there because there were so many
of them and they were so involved in
many of these programs but that's that
is a great question you stumped me but
there were there were foreigners that
were on Jason's and work with DARPA some
of the early as icons but never eller
were were not you know natural-born
American citizens so they didn't have
any kind of discrimination against
people who were born in other countries
people who had worked obviously for
Manhattan Project in other places as
well so there's I get I haven't seen it
either of it you know and actually I'm
gonna change that cuz there's one name
that I did come across Hans Ziegler he
worked at Fort Monmouth in some of the
electron yes yes so back there man hi so
um the when you go back to the brain
implant programming what about the use
of robots like where is the military
thing you have that first or they
thinking of or I guess I'd have to think
of everything at the same time but
robots already out in you know other
markets in other parts of the world so
where are they gonna learn that when are
they going to implement them on the
battlefield and how much will human how
much will it be if I cam in needing to
control that or well it need at all like
will that be a case well there are so
many DARPA robots in play presently and
and you can go to the DARPA website and
see these amazing videos I mean they
crawl they walk they climb they can fall
over and get back up there up in space
they're this big
there's robotics across every military
service and
plans the Pentagon plans of unmanned
warfare through 2038 indicate this
movement as I was saying this four-step
movement from you know remote control to
governance I think a lot of a lot of the
place where people may have heard the
name DARPA is the DARPA Robotics
Challenge which happens every year and
it's now it's become this massive thing
with different countries and everything
else yeah right up here Amanda
fascinating talk thank you and thank you
for your good moderating what are some
of the ways the DARPA morphs its its
projects into the greater public sector
do you know what I mean technology
distribution I guess you would call it
well I mean we talked about two of them
the internet and GPS and if you mean
specifically how do they just say now
it's out there I mean I become what I
understand it's a decision as it was
with GPS like Clinton and gore and then
they decide who's gonna make the
announcement and then someone does and
it's a few phone calls and it's a
declassification issue in many cases yes
yes it's also a case in many Vivaan you
said this in your talk that when other
countries have established this
technology by themselves then it's no
longer something that needs to stay
classified GPS and the ID mentioned was
a good example of this where the
Europeans and others were putting up
satellites so there was no need
necessarily to keep our program
classified anymore over there
hi what's the level of cooperation
between DARPA and JSOC in the war on
terror well I mean I think DARPA
cooperates with everyone because DARPA
from my understanding of talking to
individuals for example and that
organization is everybody wants what
DARPA has because it has all the best
stuff and so I think that it and it goes
both ways in as much that well I read
about a couple different programs in the
book where you have like a team a DARPA
team there was a program I want to say
it's Nexus 7 but it's not that it no
it's the deft program that DARPA guys
went in with JSOC in Afghanistan unclear
about you know how that actually worked
I'm sure that stuff is still classified
but most definitely cooperation from my
understanding with all the military
services I know this may be an unfair
question and if it is you can just tell
me to shut up but with all these
interesting ideas and leads that where
are you going what is your next book
going to be since it seems that one
leads to the next or your next books out
of all this effort on dark line well I
do always keep it a little under the
sleeve until I until I write the next
book but the one thing I can say is I
always loved writing about how the
agency and military intelligence work
together because there's always this
idea that they that they that they don't
it's my understanding that they really
do so the next book involves a program
that was CIA and
a Defense Intelligence Agency that's
more than I would've told that's right
we could add them turn off the c-span
camera and you get a sense of their war
over there yeah just a question thanks
for the talk there's a lot of people
from DARPA björk William gödel who you
know we're in various positions in
government before and after DARPA you
know the psychological strategy before
her Bjork went on to be the chief arms
negotiator can you talk about DARPA is
kind of a germinator for senior managers
in DoD maybe it's broader impact on
policy and people who went on to much
higher positions well that's a great
question I mean it really speaks to how
important science and technology is at
the Pentagon and of course the current
Secretary of Defense being a scientist
and a technologist but I think the first
one or I know the first one was Harold
Brown and he came directly from
Livermore he was at Livermore aged 24 he
was herb York's protege and then when he
went to the Pentagon
he was the person to whom all the DARPA
people reported to during the Vietnam
War and then in 1977 he became secretary
of defense a very very important
secretary of defense and in essence
created a really important DARPA concept
called a salt breaker which you know I
write about in the book which you know
absolutely Dom allowed the US military
to dominate in Gulf War one and that was
all science and technology driven and I
think that so that when Harold Brown was
Secretary of Defense he was able to get
money into the arena that didn't exist
before by you know certainly what the
historians had I to say by creating an
entire industry around technology at the
Pentagon
which one back over there question Amy
you alluded to the linkages between
DARPA and the intelligence community in
your research did you ever run across
any instances where DARPA benefited from
espionage either providing the seeds of
later research or suffered from
espionage where as you said they've got
the good stuff other people want to get
access to it thank you
boy that's a great question I don't know
of you know DARPA being infiltrated by
any spies in essence I I don't know but
I do know in the other way certainly
there's an incredible interplay because
these programs are so you know
interwoven Science and Technology and
intelligence but I think you know I
there was one interesting interview that
I did with because of course the CIA has
its own DARPA now it's called AI ARPA
and I interviewed intelligence Advanced
Research Project agency and they work
together a lot but I did interview
someone who was involved in the early
organization of AI ARPA and presenting
that idea to Congress and what he told
me was that the intelligence community
was very much wowed by DARPA and what
DARPA was able to do and wanted their
own model and so they really modeled
themselves after DARPA and it's even
modelled even I mean it's almost taking
DARPA back to its core where I ARPA is
just putting out contracts and contracts
and contracts for people to bid on the
ability to do advanced quantum computing
a lot of these things that are so
whiz-bang that even five years ago no
one was thinking that way and you know
and DARPA is taking that to that next
level of saying we want people thinking
30 40 years down the road listen the way
DARPA does as well back here
hi would you tell us a bit more about
how DARPA is organized - how one comes
to join DARPA how long you are there is
an appointment process or recruitment
things like that as I said it there's
generally a hundred and twenty program
managers usually people stay for its
this is sort of the way it said five
years we do have someone in the audience
who has been there for decades so you
know that is the that is the structure
allegedly but I would also remind
everyone that as with all of these
agencies you know the information that
is given is not all is often his own is
only part of the story so we know that
DARPA is very much free of red tape and
bureaucracy and because as you said
earlier they don't they don't make
things themselves they farm it all out
so it allows them this flexibility but
they do have an awfully large building
that not many reporters get into so who
knows what's really going on in there hi
I was just wondering how is DARPA today
involved with the cyber war could you
talk a little bit about that
leading all efforts if you look at the
budget you can see how many of the
programs are trying to defend against
cyber warfare I think it's interesting
that perhaps the only vulnerability I
have ever heard the Pentagon speak of is
cyber warfare in other words the
Pentagon is very clear that we have the
supremacy everywhere but admits that
cyber warfare is a enormous threat and
so I think that's I don't think DARPA
could possibly be doing enough in that
area I imagine that they are when cyber
now is the number one potential threat
to the United States supplanted
terrorism as a number one threat so
people are paying attention and there's
a lot of money going to it
certainly
any last questions oh there is one in
the back yeah I just want to know about
how do you see commercialization a sort
of the privatization that's now private
companies have access to satellites a
lot of the information about technology
and information that previously was held
to the military and do you think that
DARPA still has the edge so that versus
a foreign state can foreign power can't
use private companies to acquire the
intelligence the US and they're
challenged technical technological
superiority of the u.s. do you think
DARPA still has the edge in that sense I
would I'm sure DARPA has the edge
they have incredible satellite programs
including one that's you know lofting
satellites reusable technologies so I
think that the whole idea of what's
happening in space is having this
resurgence now that's very similar to
what it was back in 1958 I mean nowhere
is more important than satellite
technology and since DARPA job is to
keep the nation safe from technological
surprise one can only imagine how much
how much DARPA is looking up when DARPA
has always worked with private companies
as you know part of their organizational
structure and so we don't know
necessarily if a private company is
getting technological advantages on
their own or through money from dark or
somewhere else so it's nothing we're
ever going to be told no my kids may
know one day about it
the nine-time soon
any final questions I always enjoy
reading the acknowledgement sections of
the books I was just curious about your
process for writing the book and it
didn't sell out as if DARPA cooperated
in your research so you had to identify
sources that were willing to cooperate
so if you just talk about the process
for doing the research of writing the
book I always love talking to scientists
and engineers who work on these programs
and I do write about these seemingly
impenetrable subjects and it is a common
question of how do you get your sources
and I always carry with me an idea that
goes back to buy it when I wrote my book
about area 51 that a scientist named
Edie Levesque who worked with you know
Richard Bissell of the CIA and butwe lon
early CIA pioneer and in space and in
surveillance and Lovick told me two
things he said one fortune favors the
prepared mind so if you always you know
and that's quoting Pasteur but if you're
always on top of your information and
you keep current about things that are
interesting to you then people
essentially gravitate toward you to
share their stories with you and he also
told me to look up and that's a
physicists concept because these
Superman of scientists of science are
always looking up for the answers I mean
whether it's bats or Birds or the moon
or the cosmos
the answer lies from you know above and
what Lubbock was also saying to me was
you know gold higher up and he told me
that if someone if a source doesn't want
to talk to you it's probably that
they're too low down and that they can't
and seek out their boss and I have found
in this way that I find wonderful and
inspiring and important that the
greatest minds these scientists and
engineers the bud Wieland's of the world
the Charles towns of the world the MuRF
Goldberger the neo cosby's you know
people who have knowledge and
information are willing to share it if
you ask the questions
so maybe the dark
press office isn't going to give me the
information but surely 70 some-odd
scientists did for this book as they do
for all of my books and I think that's
the wonderful thing about about when you
get old and you look back on your life
as so many of these older sources of
mine do you say to yourself what can I
share with my country that I have spent
so much time you know dedicating my life
to was this vetted at all by the
Pentagon or anyone else people ask that
question I mean I'm a journalist I'm a
civilian so I don't we do yeah we we
tend to have a lot of X Agency types
here you have to go through lots of
hurdles before they can do it it's a
country and I can visit it's a major
question from the Formosan authors like
who looked at this yeah yeah right down
here just coming and a lot of part of
the book you're right about a fear among
some particularly the Essex community of
the robots taking over and we lose
control having been through this now for
three or four years do you share that I
here's what I think I begin the book
with the idea that scientists created a
weapon against which there is no defense
and cue of those scientists Enrico Fermi
and Rabi both wrote to the President of
the United States Truman at the time
this weapon should not be made it is an
evil thing that is what they called it
because they feared that there would be
no defense against it we have lived all
these decades you know it was sort of
like I hope it doesn't happen and it
hasn't but we're at a parallel situation
now in my mind and also the minds of so
many scientists I've interviewed who who
think about this question should we be
afraid of artificial intelligence and
the idea
the smartest scientist in the world is
an overwhelming majority that that Chu
could be a weapon against which there is
no defense and therefore limits must be
in place and so my fear comes from a
shared concern that comes from very
smart individuals very very smart
even Elan musk and Bill Gates and others
talking about that yeah absolutely
any last questions oh they're right
there Lauren hello and good evening
thank you so much for your time and for
the chance for all of us have an
audience with you but in regards to the
military industrial complex what are
your thoughts on how citizens can stay
well informed so that the powers stay
balanced power stays balanced and things
did not go awry I mean doing exactly
what you're doing thanks for coming
tonight you know I think just by
participating in discussions reading I
mean so much is out there thanks to
Licklider and and the Internet and then
here in America we can just read read
read read and I think that just
maintaining a knowledgeable basis it
gives you a participation in society
that's absolutely imperative some people
choose to go become you know advocates
of certain things others just remain
aware and maybe it's how they vote or
how they think or how they speak or how
they share their ideas with others but I
think you're doing a great job sitting
here tonight well on that note thank you
Annie for taking the time to come in
would you be willing to stay and sign
books of people so she will make her way
to the back and be happy to sign so
thank you very much it's great